voici le samsung galaxy s 10 plus
[Musique]
laissez moi vous parler aujourd'hui de
samsung comme vous le savez début
d'année prochaine ya les nouveaux
samsung nouveau modèle haut de gamme de
samsung qui va en sortir s10 s10 plus
est probablement un troisième modèle on
connaître en tout cas les numéros de
série de ces trois modèles pour lui es10
ce serait le smg 970 f pour le s10 plus
ça serait le smg 975 f
et pour le troisième ace 10 ce qui
pourrait être un indice light quant à
imaginer ça comme ça c'est un sng 973 f
ça c'est un petit peu comme mais ce qu'a
proposé apple cette année avec ses
iphone trois modèles un modèle un peu
standard un modèle forcément plus grand
modèle s10 s10 plus est un modèle un peu
plus low cost pour entrer dans la gamme
s10 un peu plus doucement avec un budget
un petit peu plus réduit alors ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est de
parler du s10 plus parce qu'il ya des
rumeurs qui tournent sur ce modèle et
c'est assez intéressant alors je suis
assez dubitatif de ce que j'ai vu venir
avec moi par ici ceci est un bout de cap
ça me paraît plutôt évident le hésitez
pas sorti je vois pas comment je
pourrais l'avoir encore aujourd'hui par
contre ce bout de carton c'est une créa
qui a été fait à partir d'un faux qui
ont été glanées sur la toile et ce qu'on
voit et ce qui me surprendrait
énormément de samsung et si samsung fait
ça je vous avoue que je comprends plus
rien c'est ça la sa cette espèce de vie
c'est pas une encoche parce que samsung
n'a jamais cédé au fait de mettre des
encoches sur ses smartphones un moment
la question s'est posée à savoir si sur
le sdee celle d'avoir une encoche et la
question - était quand même posé mais
très clairement et ce qu'on voit c'est
que de toute façon les encoches vont
disparaître sur les smartphones 2019
elle commence à disparaître on a vu avec
le profane geeks avec le vivent onex et
on a vu aussi avec le mx3 que j'ai vu il
n'y a pas longtemps que les encoches
allait disparaître
néanmoins est ce que ça serait une
solution serait la meilleure solution
pour intégrer les caméras je ne pense
pas je sais pas si le tiroir coulissant
comme sur le pont félix ou comme sur le
chiot me mx3 ray
la vraie bonne solution mais je suis
persuadé que ça c'est tout sauf la bonne
solution
c'est une espèce de grosse verrue
lorsque samsung apparaître les
smartphones écrans pliables il faut
montrer un peu les différentes causes
qui pourrait y avoir on pourrait aussi
avoir un petit trot mais dieu pour s est
juste passé une caméra mais là très
clairement on voit que cette année il
est ce qu'il y avoir deux caméras à
l'avant trois caméras l'arrière sur un
modèle le plus haut de gamme pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont présenté leur nouveau
socle exynos 9820 qui succède à gino ce
9810 et qui celui-ci pourrait avoir
jusqu'à cinq caméras sur le même
smartphone donc il paraîtrait logique
que 20 modèle le plus haut de gamme en
tout cas de 2019
on est trois caméras l'arrière comme
soit on trouvait actuellement chez
huawei ou comment peut retrouver sur le
galaxy à cette triple module photo à
l'arrière et double module photo à
l'avant alors qu est ce qu on pouvait
retrouver sur ces modules photo parce
que ça c'est intéressant on se trouvera
à l'arrière en premiers mots justes
photo ce serait a priori 12 mégapixels à
des couleurs variables f 1.5 être 2.4 c
est ce qu on a installé sur le galaxy s
9 et s9 plus c'est ce qu'ont aussi sur
le galaxy note 9 on pourra trouver un
deuxième module photo 16 mégapixels
ouverture de chefs 1.9 grand-angle 120
degrés pour capter effectivement des
clichés à qu'ils doivent plus grand
angle ça pourrait être sympa et un
troisième module photo qui pourrait être
un 13 mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.4
qui lui par contre atteint l'objectif
qu'ils serviraient pour avoir une fois 2
mais également pour le mode portrait
alors du coup l'avant en trouverez deux
modules photo un module photo un peu de
champ l'art pour faire des photos à
toute classique et un deuxième module
photo grand angle
ils sont d'ailleurs ajouter plus de
monde en othe selphy ça c'est ce contrat
trouver du côté de la photo et ça
justement ces permis grâce au souk gravé
en 8 nanomètres l'exynos 9820 alors à
titre d'info ce soc qui lui par contre a
vraiment été présentée de façon
officielle intègre une mali j'ai 76 au
niveau du gpu mais également elle pu
pour l'intelligence artificielle donc on
aura quelque chose qui sera plus
performant ce sera un petit peu un
équivalent de ce que représentait haye
silicone avec son kirin 980 et grâce à
ça compromet le film et jusqu en 4k à
150 images par seconde
alors qu'est ce qu'on voit aussi sur ce
nouveau modèle de samsung on verrait un
écran de 6,4 pousse forcément un écran
infiniti super amoled avec une
résolution quad hd
1280 par 1080 pixels autre point très
intéressant lorsqu'on regarde les rendus
3d que j'ai fait c'est qu'on voit qu'à
l'arrière il n'y a plus du tout de
capteur d'empreintes digitales n'aurait
pas non plus sur la tranche a priori
samsung succomberez comme a fait huawei
comme a fait wang plus comme feront
beaucoup d'autres capteur d'empreinte
digitale intégrée à l'écran directement
pour déverrouiller votre smartphone avec
votre doigt en façade
la question maintenant qu'ils restent en
suspens c'est si toutefois nous fait un
petit module photo comme ça qui est très
très vilain si en tout cas on a un petit
module photo il gardera a priori veille
seul bloc mais est ce qu'on aura face à
lui octroie des équivalents de faïza
idée ça pourrait paraître logique
seulement si on a ça là je ne pense pas
qu'il ya cette place dans la mesure où
on intègre un double module photo c'est
très intéressant parce que voyez des
rendus 3d comme ça permettra activement
de soulevé beaucoup de questions et
d'essayer de comprendre un peu là où
vallée samsung ce que va proposer
samsung les nouvelles techno parce que
il ya une vraie question qui se pose
c'est ça qui est vraiment hyper
intéressant c'est que samsung n'a jamais
su combat l'encoche mais comment est-ce
qu'ils vont intégrer leur module photo
station qu'on va toujours sur des plus
grands écrans on voit que beaucoup un
concurrent sur ses choix de lait des
tiroirs ça pourrait être une solution
pour 2019
mais samsung est toujours resté dans sa
droite ligne alors la question c'est
comment est ce qu'ils vont faire pour
intégrer en tout cas samsung
si vous faites ça j'ai j'aurais
franchement du mal à comprendre
en tout cas la prise jack devrait être
préservé le bouton bixby devrait
toujours être présent ça ça me paraît
assez logique mais on attend toujours
mix by en français ça c'est pareil ça un
peu une incompréhension parce que on
voit que on s'habitue de plus en plus à
de l'intelligence artificielle on
s'habitue de plus en plus à utiliser
google assistant à utiliser siri à
utiliser celui d'amazon pourquoi est ce
que samsung n'a pas avancé avec bixby
parce que le vrai problème c'est que
lorsque les consommateurs sont
complètement habitués à une certaine
tension artificielle s'avère d'autant
plus compliqué pour samsung d'imposer
des rubis même s'il est en français même
s'il est performant
c'est un smartphone qui tournerait sur
android 9 pas y apparaît assez logique
il aurait de l'usb type c et il pourrait
avoir un score sur en tout ou de 325000
76 en tout cas c'est ce qu'on pourrait
avoir avec à cet exil aux 9000
820 couple est assis giga de ram s'il
vous plaît messieurs dames avec 128 go
de stockage au minimum certains font
nous vient du site indien 91 'mobile' je
sais pas ce que vous pensez vous de sa
de cette espèce de truc si vous trouvez
ça bien
si samsung faisait ça est ce que vous
seriez prêt à y aller moi je serais
vraiment dubitatif et j'aurais vraiment
du mal à comprendre la stratégie de
samsung s'il ne sortait un truc aussi
aux rites comme ça en tout cas pour
l'instant c'est la dernière info en date
sorti sur les rumeurs de ce galaxy s 10
plus parce que celui avec cinq modules
photo ça serait le s10 plus dites nous
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire et
puis bien évidemment tout ça on va
reparler très prochainement y aura
d'autres infos je manquerais revoyons va
en parler en attendant je vous invite à
marquer ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire et je vous invite également
à les consulter ma playlist qui parle de
smartphones comme ça vous découvrirez
des smartphones qui eux par contre ne
sent pas en carton que j'étais septième
journée de tests en ce moment qui est
juste derrière là je ne prends pas un
trait très prochainement sans tout est
hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper hyper
impressionnant c'est le rock sound asus
et tous les accessoires
j'ai le smartphone je suis dessus depuis
quelques jours c'est à lui sinon restez
avec nous on va reparler d'ici quelques
jours
en attendant je vous invite à vous
portez bien un fait des gros bisous et
puis à très bientôt
ciao